access which is to be closed up finally
this view is taken from the highway
looking towards the site in a South
eastly sorry southwesterly Direction the
proposed two-story extension will be off
this range
here chairman it is considered that the
proposed alterations and extensions are
not sensitive or sympathetic to the host
building and the recommendation is to
refuse the application subject for the
reason detailed in the officer report
please also note that there are some
updates on the update sheet thank you
thank you very much uh okay we can now
move to our first Speaker who is
councelor Brian Keefe uh chairman of
Langley Parish
Council good evening um so you've got
three minutes in
total uh so it's the uh um was going to
say you're welcome to sit to any of
those it's the button on the right hand
side and the red light will come on and
that means that the microphone is live
thank you um I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning before your time is up if
you're happy with that
um otherwise when you're ready to take
it away thank you sir my name is Brian
Keef I lived in the village of Langley
for 27 years joined the parish council
in 2002 and been its chairman for the
last
20 the 134 adult uh members who live in
live in Langley uh whole Farm will
always be known as Gilbert's Farm after
the man who was born there who lived
there and who worked there for all of
his 85 years and when he was uh ically
died 3 years ago we were pleased that
Neil Ewings showed us his plans for for
restoring uh sympathetic restoration and
keeping with the rest of the village and
he subsequently demonstrated his
building skills in the conversion of the
adjoining roadside Barn which had
received planning permission in
September
2017 and his concern of course to
minimize disruption uh to Residence
while building all the immediate
neighbors have seen and approved of the
plans we've re received some letters
from some of them one is a a builder who
had his own business for for 30 years
and he says the proposed materials are
in keeping with the fabric of the
existing Hall farm buildings will
benefit the area and the cladding is in
agricultural
style there's also um a letter from a
property developer who happens to live
opposite and he says while it's um
refused permission in non-compliance
with cs8 cs9 cs20
SPD part G and having seen the latest
application plans it now appears to be
fully compliant and especially with SPD
G7 which encourage maintaining the
character of the building and its
setting and ensuring the converted bands
remain secondary and subservient to the
original we are pleased to note that the
wara highways have got no objection to
the new entrance which Mr eings has
created to improve the visual display uh
and to improve the safety and entry and
exit the main objection appears to be
the appearance of the twostory extension
but in two previous granted planning
permissions for listed buildings in the
village that's Spring Lane Cottage and
Mana Farm the planning officer welcomed
a different style for the extensions to
demonstrate clearly which was the
original every letter ends the same and
showing concern that the existing
buildings are getting dilapidated during
the delay and granting planning
permission and if someone who lives in a
delightful 200y old converted Barn the
need to keep on top of
dilapidations is important we very much
hope you'll be able to Grant planning
permission thank you
sir thank you very much um if you if you
want to remain seated just for a second
um we'll uh give members the opportunity
to just ask you any relevant questions
yes uh members do we have any questions
for our Parish Council
representative yes councelor Keith Le oh
thank you good good evening counselor
thank you very much for that you just
mentioned that there were two other
buildings that had been extended in the
village yes that's spring Lan Cottage
and Mana farm and were these recently
extended no the one was extended about
eight or nine years ago and the
extension is is quite different in what
respect is it different well that was
built in Brick whereas the um it it's
wooden and uh so that was a brick
extension so it was a brick extension
and the other building in the other one
men of farm they were they haven't
actually proceeded with it yet but they
got permission to have an extension
built on which would be mainly
transparent mainly metal um and and will
be tacked on to the Mana Farm
itself right thank you for that thank
you uh any further questions for Paris
Council no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution thank you
sir
okay we now move on to uh the agent for
the applicant uh which is Liz
Nicholson and we also have Neil Ying
applicant good evening both uh so yes
you have three minutes between you how
would you like to split your time uh
they should both work if not try the
next seat over sorry about
that uh yes so you've got three minutes
between you how would you like to speak
your time
speaking question lovely thank you um
again I'm happy to give you a 30 second
uh warning before your time's up
otherwise when you're ready take it
away thank you good evening your
officers consider The Farmhouse and
Associated buildings to be of historic
value and wish to see them retained the
property also lies within the green belt
and the officer report confirms that the
principle of the proposals and the scale
of development is acceptable in policy
terms oh sorry we have a slide that we
wanted to show if you've got that please
please thank you we have endeavored to
work with your officers and would have
preferred to reach a position where we
would be given a delegated approval we
requested a decision to be issued on the
first scheme so that we had an officer
report to give us a clear understanding
of the concerns regarding design we then
made a number of changes to the
proposals and submitted a
pre-application inquiry to discuss those
changes with the officer we're at
committee tonight because we were unable
to reach agreement on all the
matters you're being asked exercise your
planning judgment on design matters no
matter how many policies are written
design inevitably remains a more
subjective planning
consideration your officers want this
applicant to use traditional brick and
tile as the materials for the extension
to the house they want Windows to be
sized and designed to match the existing
windows in the house and they would like
fewer changes to the stable
building we accept that's a reasonable
design
approach however it is also entirely
reasonable for a different design
approach to be taken
and Mr eings wishes to take a holistic
approach in bringing The Farmhouse and
the associated farm buildings back into
use he has engaged a very good
architectural practice with a long
history of working on historic and
listed
buildings they have produced a
highquality contemporary design with
detailing to differentiate the new
additions from the existing brick
building fabric as they write in the
design statement this breaks down the
mass of the building cluster as a whole
and allows the history of the additions
to be clearly seen
rather than extending with new in the
style of the
old the two-story extension is in the
style of an agricultural Barn which
relates to the style of the barn
conversion already
approved Mr yings has commissioned a
report to maximize solar gain without
overheating to reduce his carbon
footprint to a minimum and the proposed
glazing is therefore part of the whole
design taking into account the
orientation of the
buildings with regards to the stable
building the boarding on the
Southeastern elevation is a modern temp
temporary measure to protect the
building from the
weather this elevation was traditionally
open and we simply wish to provide
glazed infills whilst we know the
officers are also unhappy with the
number of roof lights proposed to this
building we consider that in the
planning balance the reduction in future
energy usage outweighs the concerns
about additional re flights on an
unlisted
building in summary there is a lot of
local support for these proposals which
retain and bring back into use an old
farmhouse and we would ask that you
support the design approach taken
thank you very much well within your
time uh members do we have any questions
for our applicant or agent uh yes
councelor
har good evening Mr Nicholson um cs8 if
I can refer you to that um it specifies
that creative and Innovative designs and
architecture that helps to secure the
conservation of Heritage assets is
acceptable it's point in its favor but
it goes on to say where it
concludes provides the condition where
it is sympathetic to the character of
the local area do you think there's a
contradiction in terms in terms of an
adventurous Creative Design being
sympathetic to the local
area this is where design is a matter of
judgment isn't it um I understand what
the policy is saying uh the officers are
taking one view of how to interpret it
and we're saying with good architectural
advice that that we're we're proposing
another the left hand image there is
showing an example of this type of
cladding being used um to extend a brick
building there are examples of this
happening elsewhere and it's a judgment
for you to
make thank you any further questions C
Keithley yes thank you m Nicholson um I
picked up in the report about the roof
lights um the case officer doesn't seem
to be very happy with these roof lights
you just mentioned but it's the building
is designed for solar gain so taking
energy from the Sun through the main
Windows what what's the benefit of
having the the roof lights are they
ventilation sorry
you yeah because we're east facing we
need to grab that sun in the morning and
catch that Sun as it sits right very low
around it swings around the side of us
so we're trying as it comes around the
back to grab the Evening Sun and put
that heat back into the building as
well get more natural daylight then you
need to put your lights on less often
and heat so yeah so it's for light
lighting purp Li and heating both and
you're going to get some heat gain
through the roof lines Sun yeah okay
thank you thank you any further
questions for
members no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution
both we'll move on then to our final
speaker who is councelor Parker W member
for the
application area
good evening counselor thank you very
much good evening I'll uh as you as I
say you've got five minutes have to give
you a 30 second warning otherwise when
you're ready to take it away thanks very
much so I I'm here just to speak uh
briefly I'm hopefully known for my
brevity and I I won't disappoint tonight
um I I think as we've already heard much
of this
application uh is broadly agreeable and
we are just coming down to uh a facade
and some additional
glazing um and
uh why I'm minded to support this um
this application is because they have
kept the principal agricultural
Farmstead view very very sympathetically
on the main um Street Scene View and and
uh and we saw it uh during the earlier
presentation that is all retained and uh
any um uh wish to if you can keep that
view up I'd be grateful for my next
Point um um the
uh any desire to to do something which
one might consider flamboyant in in some
way is not on the principal view it's on
it's on a A View to the side it's going
to be largely obscured especially when
the hedges have uh have grown back also
there's an issue about blank walls and I
I'd like to look at that lower picture
there and you can see that actually on
the existing Farmstead you've only got
the two windows and then a large expanse
of brick work and I would say that that
their unglazed wall is in fact very
similar to that so uh but as uh the
previous um speaker um said very clearly
this is this is a finely balanced issue
this is the issue this is why people
like you gather so that you can help the
planning officer and the planning
process work with these fine decisions
about how we should develop um in
sensitive areas like in
Langley the last point I just would like
to raise is that um the other reason I'm
supporting this is because uh I have
interacted with the people of Langley
and there is strong support for this and
these are people uh who are there for
the Long Haul Langley does not have a
high turnover most people leave in a
coffin and uh and so it's fair to say
that when they say they're happy with
the view it is a strongly held
position check my notes make sure I
covered
everything I'm done thank you very
much thank you very much counselor uh
members any questions for our Ward
member no nothing forthcoming in which
case thank you very much for
contribution right we can now move on
then to points of clarification from our
officers are there any points of
clarification members like to
raise coun
pton thank you
chair
um the Paris Council
speaker
referenced uh other extensions which
have a sort of more
eclectic uh manner to them from his
description um we have to consider what
is in front of us but we also have to
consider a settlement and Street Scene
um and I would just like to understand
to what
extent uh officers took into account uh
other developments in Langley that on
the face of it and you and as officers
you may take a view that actually they
weren't that far away from what's there
so I would be interested to for you to
clarify what your thought process was
particularly in relation to other more
recent extensions in in langle thank you
um obviously as you know every case
assessed on its own Merit um so in
particular for the the immediate Street
SE into this area it's very traditional
very red brick um and it's felt that the
proposed extension with the um modern
material wouldn't be in keeping with the
immediate character with with what is
around
um
so I suppose just following on from that
to what extent was there any sort of
step back view of Langley and what else
has been developed around there again
looking at the broader vernacular and
character that might have been modified
B my more recent developments to what
extent was has that sort of influenced
your view on the plan planning balance
if it hasn't that's okay and that's not
a criticism it's just it's just trying
to understand and clar verify that um I
think for this one obviously we were
looking I mean I'm I'm not aware of the
properties which have been been cited um
and for obviously this one we were
looking at the immediate surrounding um
character in the area and it was felt
that the design proposed wasn't suitable
for where this is in this part of
Langley thank you any further points of
clarification for officers coun
Harvey
um there's a fre here us in your report
about the two story extension regarding
it as an in congruous feature are there
any other examples in
the relatively local area of what some
other people might regard as being an in
isn't inke keeping and because of um
because of the design of it it's um as I
say the materiality the the the color um
that that is what in in in my office of
view would give it a a stark appearance
which wouldn't obviously be compliment
ment and sensitive to the um
agricultural Farmstead um character that
that we currently have and our policy
obviously looks to preserve and enhance
um buildings which are of um
architectural Merit and obviously
represent um the former agricultural use
of of the land and the
buildings follow up on that
um I'm questioning the impact of
cs8 and the the tail end Words which say
where it is sympathetic to the to the
character of the local area do you
regard that as an absolute requirement a
threshold that must be met or is it
something where we have a degree of
interpretation can be
applied by its nature whether something
is sympathetic or not in the context of
the core strategy is a matter of
planning judgment um in our view this is
not a sympathetic addition and so it
fails against
cs8 that doesn't quite answer my point
my point was um not whether it is or
whether it isn't sympathetic the
question was whether it is a requirement
of the policy to come to the Judgment
that it is sympathetic in order to
satisfy
CSA yes members would need to be
satisfied that it is sympathetic if they
were to conclude it was going to meet
the requirements of cs8
thank you cast Keithley yeah thanks very
much um I suppose my question is really
about the design as well it being a
matter of some subjectivity what some
people would see as
a a good design or an acceptable design
others might not see that um on page 11
halfway
down uh this is just a question on
clarification really um you say although
I appreciate this elevation you're
you're talking about the Northwest
elevation of the proposed two-story
extension has no openings although I
appreciate this elevation is set back
this will be visible from the highway
and the lack of openings creates a stark
facade which will be even Starker as a
result of the facing
materials when I read
spdg um in there I saw that in fact we
were saying that the number of openings
on this type of barn style should be
kept a minimum and I've got I'm I'm a
bit confused as to whether or not we
should be saying that openings are a
minimum or a facade is St because it
doesn't have any
openings are there some further design
modifications given the facing materials
that we're looking at that would meet G
but you know are there some design
modifications that the applicant could
propose that that would meet or is it is
there no Prospect of that and I'm
thinking about the the cladding that
they proposed yeah so um I think we need
to look at this in two parts so the
twostory extension is to the existing
dwelling um so um obviously that's um
whilst it is obviously it's the um
agricultural Farmstead it's um unlike
the stable range the stable range is the
um obviously traditional stable range
and in part G it's um um my view would
be that it would be this the stable
range where we' be looking to limit
limit the openings so an extension to
obviously the main
Farmstead um in terms of the number of
openings that that has I think you would
look to see whether or not that was
appropriate within within the design um
to the extension of of the building so
um an extens I think an extension to The
Farmstead um we'd want it to be the
number of openings to be to be
appropriate to the extension once before
look at it at in terms of the street
scene and the character of what that
extension looks like to the extension to
the house um and part G um relating to
new openings um my my understanding my
reading of that is where obviously we do
have um like a historic stable which is
looking to be converted we're looking to
keep openings to to a minimum so that we
are retaining the character of um of
that of that part of the building so
like retaining features such as barn
doors um to to maintain the character
and appearance of effectively how the
building has historically being and
interacted with the
land follow that up okay so I did I
think I understood that but you're
working on the premise that the
extension of The Farmstead is to look
like an extension of a Farmstead and
what I saw was was from certain view the
applicant is trying to make the
extension of The Farmstead actually look
like an agricultural Barn which is
attached to The Farmstead now my family
had a farm and you know some of the
barns were very very close to the farm
house
so in my mind the applicant is trying to
seek to create a barn style extension
from one
view I think this
is okay all
right but I'm I'm trying to
understand why we're talking about um
part G with with no windows or no
openings in a barn style and the
officers talking about The
Farmhouse
extension I'm just trying to get that
sorted out in my
head yeah one thing I would maybe say is
obviously if um for this
proposal they're looking to incorporate
the stable range into part of the
residential dwelling so if I think
probably an easy way to think about this
maybe is if the stable range wasn't part
of The Proposal we would just be looking
at the main Farmhouse as an as as the
character of the extension to the
dwelling so um obviously because we are
introducing the stable range to this um
to incorporate it into the
scheme that's obviously not in a
residential use at the moment and I
think the guidance is clear where we
have existing buildings um which are St
Stables um or other agricultural
buildings that we seek to retain the
character of those
elements thank you uh I believe was it
councelor edin
next thank you chair
um forgive me my head is getting a bit
turned around by a lot of what we've
seen but we've been talking about taking
a step back and
um looking at it sympathetically or
otherwise um on your initial
presentation Amy you put up a a photo
from the roadside and you flashed it up
while counselor Keithley was talking
earlier that's the
fella I might have misheard but you
indicated on that drawing where the the
larger the the blue gray extension was
going and is that on this roadside
facing
I believe that's what you said but can
you just confirm that for me yeah that's
correct so it's um projecting off this
elevation so if I go to the floor plan
um it's just off the
side uh councilor Fleming
next yeah um just clarification on
balance really um looking through the
the report um on page 10 we've got I
consider the proposed side extensions
small link would be considered small
scale and further down in that paragraph
you said um I therefore find the
proposal as appropriate development in
the green belt and Accords with the core
strategy policy and also on page 11
we've got um talking about the the black
cladding which has now been sorted it
wouldn't be sensible um to the to the
roof material but we've corrected that
point then in paragraph three would not
be considered harmful as they will
balance the elevation and match the
style and design of the existing
fenestration then at the bottom
paragraph um this is is a modern the
glaze link is a modern connection
feature and I do not consider it would
be a harmful introduction so the things
that you've then turned around and said
you want to refuse this do they outweigh
or have more weight than these three
things that you've already said don't
cause any problem and and and are uh you
know acceptable
I think cumulatively it's looking at as
a whole um and in in my view
um the overall
harm from from cumulatively isn't there
in terms of obviously green belts
um the proposals in terms of their size
and scale whilst they do satisfy Green
Belt policy in terms of their design and
appearance that's where um obviously I
have I have the
concerns I think to be clear if members
are looking at the individual elements
of The Proposal in design terms and you
consider for example that the glazed
link is acceptable or the barn
conversion is acceptable but the side
extension is not you should still
consider that the conflict with planning
policy in respect to the side extension
would mean that you follow the officer's
recommendation and refuse the
application on the other hand if you
think that all elements of it are
acceptable in design terms you would
perhaps consider whether an over
overturn of the officer's recommendation
would be
appropriate c
passingham um I've been to Langley quite
recently and my recollection is there's
quite a lot of what could be called
Innovative houses there so but so my
question is when you're talking about
Street Scene how far does the street
scene go what is the range could you
have you got a radius or something that
that is normally acceptable for a seek
streen I think every again every case is
on a Case by case depending on where you
are but I think for this one I think
this this map probably sum sums up quite
nicely sort of the area where we would
be considering it within its immediate
context so you can see the various
dwellings which are just
here thank you any further points of
clarification from our
officers no in which case case we can
move to debate who would like to
start councelor
Holmes yes so in my view what's been
demonstrated uh tonight I think the
creative and Innovative design is
sympathetic to the car the area I think
what's proposed is a sympathetic
restoration and it preserves the formal
Agricultural and farm buildings in style
of other agricultural buildings in the
area
um I'd like to hear other counselor's
views but I'm inclined to um support
this
application thank you very much Council
pton thank you
chair uh members have asked a
significant number of questions of
clarification of the officers which is
right and proper and our officers have
given
detailed and rational responses um
unfortunately members it's not actually
helpful to us because the bottom line
here is that this is a question of
design and design like beauty is in the
eye of the beholder it is a finely
balanced decision um I am minded to feel
that
overall this design adds more than it
subtracts I absolutely
understand how and why officers have
come to the conclusion that they do is a
finely balanced one and I would have no
criticism whatsoever of officers in in
how they've arrived at their conclusion
uh because there are some there are some
challenges and innov Innovation does
lead to that um so I I think this is one
we're we're absolutely on our own with
this one uh as decision makers uh we
we're not going to get a Magic Bullet
From officers one way or the other on
this
um I am minded to be alongside councelor
homes on this one I will however Reserve
certainly making any kind of proposal
until I've heard what other members have
to say thank you um we'll go to councel
Harvey next but I'll just remind members
that um if we are looking to go against
officers recommendations we need uh
policy grounds to go on that so I'll
just put that out there at this point so
that that can be mold on C Harvey thank
you chairman uh I'm sympathetic to this
application in view of the um support
that it engenders
locally people of of standing within the
local community have expressed their
point of view
however um I don't think it's a matter
of dispute that the design particularly
for the extension is different uh
significantly different and and the
applicant has made Merit of it this is a
definite statement and in in that sense
it fulfills cs8 in the sense of being
creative
and yep being creative and it is an of
an Innovative design however um the
materials that are being used for the
extension are not traditional they're
non-traditional the amount of glazing
the officer has pointed to that as being
a matter for her concern I can see why
she why she says that uh and the
critical point for me was the answer to
the question given by the planning
manager that it is essential for us for
a for
a proposal to be compliant with
cs8 that it should satisfy the condition
where it is sympathetic to the character
of the local area and much as I would
reinforce my earlier comments that I'm
sympathetic given its local support in
conscience I can't say that this is
sympathetic to the character of the
local area and on that basis I would
support the officer's recommendation and
if required for clarity I will propose
that is the
case thank you counselor uh councel
Holmes to come back in um I'll take an
opposite View and I think that the
application does um qualify with policy
cs8 uh that it is sympathetic to the
character of the local area and I think
I'd recommend those as the grounds to
approve the
application uh councelor scora
next thank you chairman uh to me I mean
I I do like the uh the modern design uh
I think it's a good Jos with the uh the
old building the house I think it's good
design it does does look uh quite
agricultural to me from an agricultural
background um I think it Blends in and I
think over time I think it will blend in
with the village so I would support uh
this
application thank you very much Council
Eden next thank you chair
um I agree in part with councilor scora
in terms of it is good design there's no
question about that but equally I fall
back on a lot of what councelor Harvey
was saying in terms
of it not quite all adding up and my
question when I clarified it was the
view from the street scene and the
extension part for me Isn't sympathetic
so on that
basis um the local support is also very
important but on that basis I think I
will second councel hary's proposal to
refuse
uh can I just be clear Council Harvey
did you make a proposal to refuse in
line with officer's recommendations I
did thank you okay uh so that's been
seconded by Council Eden um I'm Happ to
go U on with the debate but clearly
there have been a number of views um
which are quite divided um so I'll just
remind members at the moment I've have
one proposal which has been seconded to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendations
um thank I believe Council holes I'm I'm
happy to make a formal proposal to
approve the
application okay thank you um and
councelor keithy next yeah just just
quickly really just to say that it is a
very much a subjective judgment um in
some eyes the proposed extension of The
Farmstead would be good design but in
other eyes it would be potentially quite
in congruous in its location
um not fitting with the street scene the
applicant we heard has had through the
agent has had some discussions with the
officer they' not been able to meet in a
common ground which suggests to me that
there were
potentially
um the applicant I felt maybe was just a
little bit fixed in what they were
proposing um my view is that
um I think the in congruity of the
extension for me is going to make me
lean
towards um the refusal which is a
recommendation by
officers thank you very much okay
um looks like we're moving towards the
end of the debate uh we have a proposal
from Council of homes to go against
officers recommendations uh which hasn't
been seconded as yet oh okay so that's
now been seconded by councelor pton um
would anyone else like to speak on this
councelor
passingham yeah um it's obviously a very
very subjective opinion and and I'm
leaning towards that it's in the style
of a an agricultural building and it's a
barn but I I think they've been very uh
Innovative in in terms of Energy
Efficiency and the environment in the in
the Solar gain and the ground Source
heat pump and overall I think if you
take it that it's sympathetic in terms
of it's an agricultural style building
uh I think the
balance it complies with cs9 and the
balance in terms of uh the planning
balance I'm uh in favor of the
development thank you very much uh if no
one else is looking to contribute to the
debate we can move on to to the votes
now we've had two
proposals um the first that was seconded
was to refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation so that's one we shall
hear first and that will determine what
happens next so I have a proposal uh to
refuse application in line with officer
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
please that's four chairman four and
opposed
five
abstentions one CH okay so that proposal
has fallen in which case we can now move
to our second proposal which is to Grant
the yeah uh Grant the uh application um
now I just need at this point to be
absolutely clear on the reasons for that
and to consult our officers for
conditions so councelor homes can you
please just clarify the exact reasons um
well I think that the main thing where
the um interpretation was that the uh
application was in contrary to cs8 um I
believe it it is actually for it and
that that it that it is a creative and
Innovative design sympathetic to the
character the area um in in the design
of the building um I'm not sure if
there's any other points that need
clarifying thank you very much much uh M
Jeff does that satisfy your requirements
I'm content um with what I've heard
members take the view that the uh Works
to the stable range are acceptable and
sympathetic that the side extension
likewise is in an Innovative material
but that reflects an architectural style
and and therefore can be considered
sympathetic as
well and um with regards conditions I I
understand you'll have some of those
prepared
yep um so the standard time um condition
um develop in accordance with plans land
contamination land remediation and um I
think within my report I noted that they
need to provide some more information in
regards to ecology so we would look for
those to be pre pre- commencement
conditions in anti obviously we normally
get the agreement the wording of those
in anticipation of tonight's meeting I
did go back to um the agent who was
happy with um potential wording for
those conditions if members were minded
to um support um also a material
schedule um climate change checklist um
water butt and um something members may
want to um con consider um the removal
of PD rights um that's something we
would look to do on um buildings of this
character to retain their um obviously
character and um style and to prevent um
any any harmful forms of
development thank you very much um I
trust that's acceptable to the proposal
in seconder um and the wording of those
would be delegated to officers okay uh
we can now move on to the vote for that
proposal so proposal is to Grant
application uh for the reasons given
conditions to be um wording to be
finalized uh delegated by officers can I
see all those in favor
please that's five chairman thank you
opposed four chairman and
extensions one thank you very much in
which case um committee resolves to
Grant application
23269 ful Hall Farm Spring Lane
Langley
okay we'll just uh let the the public
Gallery uh adjust and then we can move
on to item five which is application
35f Meadow Cottage Alston Lane Alston
Stratford on aen um our presenting
officer is again am flute when you're
ready take
away thank you
chairman the sites donated by the black
dot is within alvon and its Associated
built-up area boundary a public foot
paath runs to the site's eastern
boundary and crosses the access point
the conservation area ABS the site's
eastern boundary which can be seen by
the pink purple line um and again um
crosses the access point um the site is
within flood zone 1 to three and
planning permission is sought for um the
erection of a dwelling in this land
here the proposed site plan can now be
seen the dwelling would be cited
Northeast of the adjoining property
Meadow um Cottage um and a new access um
would be proposed off the existing
access the proposed elevations and floor
plans can now be seen the proposed
dwelling is approximately 9.8 MERS to
the Ridge and will be constructed from
Red Brick blue lifestone and a slate
roof this image is looking in a
northwesterly direction Meadow Cottage
and existing trees within the site can
be seen the public footpath runs um just
behind these trees
here um this image is taken looking in a
South westly direction towards the rear
of meadow Cottage um which can be seen
and also the adjacent Hillside
development can just be seen
here um this image is looking towards
the site eastern boundary so um the
public footpath runs
um behind the that tree line
line um and this image is taken from the
existing access and shows the adjoining
public footpath and and new access um to
serve the site will be created in this
area chairman it is not considered that
the proposal is um in an acceptable
location due to flood risk the design
and scale is considered to be
inappropriate for this edge of
settlement location and insufficient
information has been submitted in
relation to tree tree protection the
recommendation is to refuse the
application subject to the reasons
detailed in the report and please note
there are also some updates on the
update sheet thank you thank you very
much Amy uh okay we can now move on then
to our first speakers uh who are we have
three for this section which is David
Tucker and Jane Dodge of uh alvon
villagers
Association okay that's absolutely fine
uh we also have Oliver Spicer agent for
the application uh so you've got 3
minutes between you um how would you
like to split your
time
y yeah I'm sure our officers will look
at that um okay um so shall I give you a
a 30 second warning before your time is
up um and
then 15 seconds of fine and then um yeah
you take it on from there okay good well
um yes it's the button on the right hand
side to turn the microphone on and uh
otherwise when you're ready take it
away sorry could you just turn your turn
your M microphone on
please yes yeah just the microphone is
button on the right hand
side on the right hand side if it's not
[Music]
working no any and more work should do
it okay sorry about that there is right
can I start again yeah when you're ready
uh the haters have consulted throughout
their application with the alvaston
village Association and importantly
extensively with the village neighbors
who are all totally
supportive the Ava planning committee
has had two site meetings at which
recommendations were made and
subsequently
adopted set on a one acre plot and of
relatively small scale this
three-bedroom house built in materials
complimenting the local vernacular is a
useful addition to the housing stock and
importantly complies with our village
design
statement the foot paath referred to is
very little used and for much of its
short 200 meter length is dark and
intimidating adjacent to the application
site it is framed by hedging and trees
with very limited views View and where
there are views the existing garage and
house and the three massive new houses
already under construction dominate the
site has hidden and has no impact on the
street scene and contributes to alon's
Unique area thank
you thank you Su successful planning is
about consistency in decision- making
and tonight this committee is the
decision maker the application before
you is reported having three concerns
David is just outline the significant
local support for the application from
local residents the Ava and specifically
why the design is supported it meets The
Village design statement objectives the
design of this dwelling is a positive
addition to Alon known as a hidden
village and utilizes many local
materials and traditional forms to add
to this local quality the case officer
has noted that the popular tree known as
T1 has needs to require tree protection
fencing this can be conditioned in line
with the other trees that we've
preserved on the site with an
appropriate condition
finally the officer raised concern on
the flood zone and assessed the
application in an inconsistent manner
the proposed dwelling is entirely not in
a flood zone the access road is within a
flood zone the EA EA have not objected
nor have they requested a sequential
test the EA have no issue with the plan
application the EA have on three on on
the three adjacent new dwellings noted
no objection either and advised the
roadway access was acceptable on all of
these applications I have the response
here if you wish me to expand upon this
the three applications noted in 2017 18
and 19 under the current local plan and
NP ppf were approved by Lise Coleman
Alice Allison young and Sarah de baros
and subsequently Amy flu approved plans
to replace all three dwellings with much
larger modern versions in
22 the application is already signed up
to the flood warning system and I would
urge that the committe impose a
condition for all future occupants to be
obliged to do so too to summarize good
design is supported by the local
Ava and there are no objections the
trees can be protected with a minor
update via condition and the FL flood
issue can be turned into a positive by
this committee conditioning no PD rights
resulting in no further building in the
flood zone so we urge you to support
this application tonight thank you very
much just about to ask you to wrap it up
and there you did so thank you very much
um okay members do we have any questions
for our agent for the application or
Alon villagers Association Cutler Harvey
just a question of fact the
um on page 24 the report mentions on the
last line the applicant wishes to claim
self-build exemption is this an
application for a self-build house
please um this is an application for a
new dwelling um for uh the owners of
meadow Cottage who are going to who've
lived there for 17 years and are going
to move into the property um the
self-build nature is for seal liability
in terms of building for themselves so
the s liability um is retained for 3
years so should they sell it within 3
years they have to pay a seal
contribution that that's the nature of
uh
self-build thank you very much uh any
further questions Council
pton uh just in terms of helping me
orientate myself broadly where is the
the site for the new dwelling you've got
the three modern dwellings in the
foreground is is he aimed at me or the
planning officer well you can you can
you can tell me you're the guy design
where it's going to be so if I can
orientate the three dwellings of this
photo are the recent permissions in 2017
18 19 2022 um you'll see the white
rendered building in the center uh and
the access way goes from horizontally
from the white rendered building through
those trees to the main road where you
can see the houses in the far distance
um all of those houses use the same
access roadway um which as I mentioned
the environment agency have no objection
to and then the land behind the the
furthest red building behind the white
building that little area to the side of
that building which is a converted
garage Annex um is the site for the new
dwelling um outside of the flood
zone any further questions for
members no in which case thank you both
for your
contribution okay we move on then to our
final speaker who is W member councelor
Rolf good evening
counselor uh so yes you have 5 minutes
I'm happy to give you a 30 second
warning um otherwise when you're ready
rotate to take it
away the way I see this is there are
three ISS issues the planner is concerns
with all of which can be dealt with very
simply tree protection the big pop tree
tr1 does not belong to the applicant it
is in fair condition with minor Decay a
tiny bit of the patio encroaches on root
protection area and the applicant will
put in proper protection to the roots
tr15 and tr22 which are both in fair
condition the proposed driveway does not
encroach on root protection area of
either tree but the applicant is more
than happy to put in extra protection
where necessary if you wish to to
condition this just to add that the
submitted Arbor cural report confirms
the impact on the surrounding trees is
acceptable and there was no objection
from the county ecologist the size of
the property the current delling sits on
a 2 Acre Site and this proposed dwelling
will sit on one acre of that this is a
three-bedroom two-story house which is
almost a third of the size smaller than
the house the applicants are currently
living in this will be their forever
home so they can live comfortably in the
village of alvaston where they have
lived for the past 17 years with their
friends and neighbors around them the
house will only be seen by a tiny
pathway where only a handful of local
dog walkers use and will not be seen
from either alvaston lane or the main
wellsborne road Plus for the most of the
year you will not be able to see it at
all because of the trees and hedges
being in leaf there will be absolutely
no encroachment on the countryside view
which adds to the character of alviston
being a hidden village the first
application on this was withdrawn as the
planner was not happy with the position
of the new dwelling so the applicant
moved the building around to satisfy the
planner the design scal sighting and
appearance have been developed with the
planning officer and are supported by
the village residents the Alston Village
Association and myself the design uses
local materials in an appropriate way to
transition transition from the modern
builds under construction next to the
site and back to the Village tradition
you will also note that the two-story
element is closest to the existing
building and the single story part
nearer to the edge and plot of the
public right away the driveway up to the
house there is an established driveway
up to the current house and to the three
under new construction new houses next
door this driveway passes through flood
zones 2 and three but access was never
mentioned as being an issue for all
three houses next door so I don't
understand why there is a problem now in
fact the planner hasn't even mentioned
the very large and dominant three houses
very close by and I'm curious as to why
they are not shown on any of the
pictures they are there though the owner
of the former demolished Cottage next
door had lived there over 50 years and
had never had an issue with access let
alone flooding and the current
applicants have never had an issue with
driving in or out and the environment
agency doesn't have a problem with this
at all if the committee were minded to
approve this application then a
condition to ensure the driveway was
made of permeable material and included
a couple of passing points could be
added another condition could be put in
requiring the occupants to to sign up to
the early warning flood alert system
flood Angel to allow for the occupants
to make arrangements should they be
needed one more extremely important
thing to mention in 2018 when the
application was approved on the three
houses you see before you being built on
the next door site the planner Allison
young stated with respect to the site
access which does lie within flood zones
2 and three the EA considers that
sufficient lead in time is available to
allow potential residents to either stay
on site where the water will be too deep
for a few hours before becoming passable
again on the access into the site or
leaving plenty of time before any event
they have also taken into consideration
the velocities of the water in any flood
event which they State a very low within
the site I therefore consider that the
proposed development would comply with
the core strategy policy CS4 and I think
we need to look at consistency in
decisions on this this proposed new
dwelling sits entirely within flood zone
1 and and totally outside of flood zone
2 and three if it helps your decision I
and my colleague councelor perel are
putting forward a motion next week to
prevent where possible further
development on flood zones 2 and three
so it would seem very hypocritical of me
to be to be supporting this application
if I had any doubt whatsoever the entire
Village are happy with this application
and there have been no objections The
alviston Village Association have looked
at it carefully and the resi revised
designs positions and appearance were
fully discussed and everyone is fully
supportive of the scheme may I just note
one of the members of this Association
has just spoken in support I would
therefore ask you to support this
application thank you very
much thank you councelor Ral just within
your time well done um members do we
have any questions for our W
member no nothing forthcoming in which
case thank you very much for your
contribution
okay uh we can now move on then to
points of clarification from our
officers counc pton just a very quick
one I'm assuming the three properties in
the foreground that's the hillside
development that's referred to in the
update sheet that's correct yeah okay
they look a lot at that angle they look
like they'd be a lot taller than the the
uh yes okay so they're relatively low
level buildings and you can see Hillside
in this image here which is looking back
towards the meadow Cottage yeah that uh
thank you that's
helpful KLA Harvey thank you chairman um
page 22 the officers um drawn attention
to policy be6 of the NDP which states
the builtup areas uh should appear to
emerge from the surrounding Countryside
I can understand that um the second line
however the building's height should be
restricted uh near all entrances to the
Village given the site of this proposal
can that be said to be at the entrance
to the
Village I think we have to consider that
there is a public footpath which does
enter into the village so my my view is
obviously the site AB buts a public
footpath which is an entry point into
the village for
Walkers councelor Keithley
next I had two questions um the first
was along the lines that councilor
Harvey um asked because this development
is is right on the periphery of the
builtup area boundary am I right in
saying
that um it's sort of closest to the edge
of the builtup area boundary yeah if you
bear with me two seconds I can um pull
up the builtup area boundary plan if
that's helpful yeah um so so the
question I was going to ask was was
about the same sort of thing as you
enter the village and you see a gradual
um evolution of buildings you already
seeing the buildings that are next door
uh to my mind um before you see the
almost the new building um I don't I
don't I don't understand that maybe
that's not a question so I'll turn to my
second question um which is about the
flood uh flooding issue and the fact
that the EA have not objected and that
there's a flooding issue only on the
access road potentially which is three A
or B I don't know which could that be
sort of conditioned in the in the um in
the uh Grant of a permission if that was
the case uh that that that the as we
heard from councelor rol that the um the
road could be made of certain types of
materials so that access was was not
prevented perhaps or not so restricted
yeah hopefully I can help members here
um the planning officers report refers
to the sequential test the aim of the
sequential test is to steer new
developments to areas with the lowest
risk of flooding from any source and
development should not be allocated or
permitted if there is a reasonable
available alternative site for the
proposed development in an area of lower
flood risk in terms of what the
environment agency have
said um I'll read from their comments if
that's okay uh sequential and exception
tests they say paragraph 162 of the
national planning policy framework
requires decision makers to steer new
development to areas at the lowest
probability of flooding by applying a
sequential test it states that
development should not be allocated or
permitted if there's a reasonably
available site appropriate for the
proposed development in areas with a
lower probability of flooding further
detail is provided in the National
planning policy guidance only when where
there is no reasonably available sites
in flood zones one or two should the
suitability of sites in flood zone 3 be
considered taking into account the flood
risk vulnerability of land uses as
outlined above parts of the proposed
development include site access appear
to be located within flood zone 3 based
on the scale and nature of the proposed
Lo proposal located within zones 3 which
is considered non- major development in
accordance with the DMO we would not
make any bespoke comments on the
sequential test in this instance the
fact that we are not providing comments
does not mean that there are no
sequential test issues but we leave this
for your Council to
consider in saying so the environment
agency leave us to consider where there
are reasonably alternative sites for a
single OpenMarket dwelling in the
district or not our view as officers is
that with a healthy 5-year housing land
Supply
that there is plentiful supply of
alternative locations for a single
Market dwelling in the
district um and just going back to the
built of area boundary um so the site is
here um so the black line denotes the
built-up area boundary and um just for
reference the green line is the public
footpath and this area shaded pink is
the land which is within the
Conservation
Area
thank you any further points of
clarification from our
officers I have one just um for my own
um sense of clarity um do you have
available the um flood maps for this
area yep I can just get those for you
now um so I've just done a rough outline
of the the site
um so part of the um so the darker area
is flood zone fre the lighter blue is
flood zone 2 and the white area is flood
zone one and then this is um the um
strategic flood map so it shows um the
breakdown so we've got um so the site is
approximately here um so part of the
access um within flood zone um
three okay so just for clarity the the
whole area of the site which is flood
zone one is
surrounded by either zones want two or
three is that correct from from the maps
yeah that's correct okay thank you uh
any further points of
clarification U passingham and
then the the building is outside the
builtup area um we we only just outside
but in it's not oh it's within the
builtup area boundry for for the Village
um but obviously in office of view
because of its sighting it's it's on
it's on the edge sort of away from the
kind of existing built
form Castle Kei Le yeah and my question
is about your uh reason for refusal
three which is about the trees and the
protection of the trees I think we heard
from councelor rol that um there were
some potential mitigation measures
available to protect the trees um is
that a matter that could be conditioned
as well um I think given obviously the
amount of um incursion into some of
those root root protection areas it it
something which we could condition but
normally we would expect to have that
full detail up front in accordance with
British standards um so so I think you'd
have to be comfortable um with with
obviously seing that by condition I
thought I'd heard that there was an
aboriculture report um there was but it
didn't it didn't um it didn't go into
sufficient detail to um indicate so
where where there was incursion into
repr protection areas um giving us
exactly how the methods for um ensuring
that the protection of that tree would
take place okay thank you for that thank
you any further points of
clarification no in which case we can
move on to debate who would like to
start I'll pick on someone otherwise
counc
Ren okay
okay so from my point of view there is
an area of land that is surrounded by a
flood zone with buildings in it and
adding another one as far as I can
see isn't really a a vast amount of
harm that's about as far as I've got so
we'll go with everybody else
there Buck well ped thank you councelor
Keithley yeah thanks very much I mean
mean I'm just turning to um this issue
of of the um building in the edge of the
builtup area boundary and this little
footpath which runs through the trees
and how um we're seeing that that the
the
the the buildings that we're putting on
the edge of the buop area boundary need
to be such that the village sort of
emerges to you as we walk towards it but
what I've heard is that this is a path
that's very little used I can imagine it
is quite dark inside all those trees
there's no local objections to this
application so in my view I think that
um the scale and mass of the building as
it's been presented with discussions
with the officer where the lower level
area is towards the footpath and given
that there's some very very large houses
being built quite close by I'm not sure
for me that the emergency of buildings
um and then being uh an imposing view
from the footpath is a particular issue
I think the trees could be conditioned
and um I'm minded to be inclined towards
agreeing with Council Eden about the
flooding which might be a relatively
minor risk on the access road and not
for the actual property itself thank you
Council P pton thank you um
the question of you know use or you know
frequency of uses of a foot path isn't a
isn't a planning consideration in that
sense at all there is a foot paath foot
paths are gateways into
settlements
and it is an established principle that
at the edge of settlements you you try
to sort of graduate up
and the applicant has the the closest
part of the development
is single story but it but rapidly turns
into a really quite tall building a
building that of
itself overshadows Jasmine Cottage and
were the owners of Jasmine Cottage not
as I understand the owners of Jasmine
Cottage are the
applicant Meadow Cottage Meadow Cottage
where did I get Jasmine from it's been a
long day one there's the other one
anyway the you know one could imagine
that the were the owners of the cottage
not the applicant there would be
questions raised around overbearing Mass
etc etc and we have and I was quite
surprised when I looked at the the
buildings in the foreground they look
and I suspect they are big properties
but they looked the the view from that
they look quite tall but actually when
you look at it in the update sheets
they're relatively low-level buildings
so what we've got at the moment is foot
paath the edge of the settlement
you've got a you've got a cottage
Cottage with no name and then you which
is relatively low scale and then you've
got what are quite large buildings but
relatively low level so you have got
that and for me this seems to be
introducing quite a big building right
at so you're going up and then you're
going down which to me cuts across this
whole notion of gradually moving up so I
can see where officers are from with
this one um about the mass and the scale
of the building
um and I'm probably leaning towards
supporting the officers on this
one thank you councelor Fleming
next I was going to talk about exactly
the same thing as as councelor pton but
I see it from a slightly different point
um this is a three-bedroom detached
house and it's going to be adjacent to
three very large um floor area uh
developments um although they're not
quite as tall
um I don't I don't think the harm to the
to the environment is uh is dependent on
the fact that they're slightly taller
the the this are somewhat subjective
until in terms of how we we feel that on
the edge of a a settlement um and that
that's one aspect the big that concerns
me the most is the flooding um in
relation to the
site the fact that it's completely
surrounded by flood zones two and three
is a massive concern for me and I think
we need to be incredibly careful when
we're considering applications of this
type to some extent as counc Eden opened
up you know it's a it's a plot in you
know on on an area of flood zone one I'm
wondering where the water from that
flood zone one is going to go um that's
my main concern at the moment but I also
agree um with some of Council of pton
points around uh the public uh right of
way being sort of extent irrespective of
uh amount of use um that's my feelings
at the moment so they're generally in
line with the officers uh
recommendations but as I say U Mr jeffre
want to come in on a flood Point as well
so I'll let him do that now thank you
chair um couple of things I heard in
respect of of of flood risk were a bit
concerning um the nppf provides that
inappropriate development in areas at
risk of flooding should be avoided by
directing development away from areas at
highest risk whether existing or in the
future members in looking at this
application you have to consider the
whole of the development not just the
building the garden the access to and
from it members have to understand that
when someone lives in a place like this
access is a key feature you know
emergencies happen not just one at a
time often twice at a time you know if
this place floods what happens if
someone is in it and has a heart attack
those are the sort of issues members
should be weighing up our own
policies CS4 in particular um States
development within the environment
agency's flood risk zones 2 and 3A will
only be acceptable when the sequential
test and where applicable the exception
test have been satisfied as set out in
the National planning policy framework
members to approve this application you
have to be satisfied that this passes a
sequential test the sequential test
requires you to be satisfied that there
are not alternative locations that you
could locate a single Market house
dwelling in the
district thank you uh councelor Harvey I
think that's a very powerful point if I
may say so um my my concern is uh is
different um and it relates to what
council Fleming has referred to slightly
higher roof ridg line um this isn't
slightly higher this in my view given
the information in the update sheet
we're talking about a difference between
6.2 and I can understand why a building
on the edge of this Village uh at 6.2
was considered to be acceptable part of
the stepping up as you approach The
Village whereas this proposal is for a
ridge height which is 50% higher more
than 50%
higher uh the this the stipulation is in
the NDP policy we're fre frequently I've
heard from parish and town counselors
that what's the point of having ndps and
uh unless planning Authority is going to
actually take some note of them here we
have an instance where this this this
NDP which went to a referendum which was
which was agreed and uh by by local
residents to support the instance that
Building height should line the building
height line should be restricted near
all entrance to the village and as
councelor pemon has has said there is an
entrance to the Village on the foot path
so in in my in my terms having regard to
respect the NDP and the terms given the
scale the 50% increase this is over the
planning application in relation to
Hillside which was approved given the
concerns the officer has has has raised
about
massing and scale I think that holds
water so to
speak so I am
no pun intended I am inclined to to go
along with the officer's recommendation
not only for the height uh but also of
the flooding issues that the planning
manager has
raised thank you councilor Keithley yeah
thanks I I mean to some extent I am
swayed by the argument put forward by my
friend councelor pton about the entrance
to the village and the fact there a foot
path regardless of how many people come
on it but I would point you to page 23
on residential amenity when Mr start
talking about the impact of this new
house on the meadow Cottage next door
and it says due to the relation of the
dwellings I'm satisfied there will be no
breach of the 45 to 25 degree sight
lines from either property and thus I do
not consider the proposal would have an
unacceptable impact with regards to
overlooking overbearing overshadowing or
loss of light impact on that Cottage
next door I just wanted to bring that to
your
attention thank you um any further
contribution yes c p I'm just prepared
to put for for a proposal that we accept
officers recommendations if I can find a
seconder for that alternatively I'll
wait for other debate by members thank
you I'm prepared to second that um
members do we have any further
contributions quite happy to hear
them in which case we have a proposal
which has been seconded and we'll be
looking to move to the
vote okay so proposal is to refuse
application in line with officers
recommend ation can I see all those in
favor seven chair
opposed one chair and exensions two
chair in which case committee resolves
to refuse application 23
Fu hey um I
eight urgent business no chairman in
which case I can close the meeting thank
you very much
everyone